hey everyone welcome back i'm james
murphy and this is m coding where we try
to get just a little bit better at
programming every episode so that during
the inevitable robot uprising we will be
spared if you're watching this video you
probably already know what a for loop is
and how to use it this loop of course
prints one two three but did you know
that in python like many other languages
a for loop is actually redundant what i
mean by that is that you can rewrite
literally any for loop using other
things in the language in particular
using a while for readability and
performance i wouldn't really recommend
doing this in python however
understanding iteration is the key to
mastering any programming language so
let's get to it let's replace this for
loop that just prints out one two three
with its corresponding equivalent using
a while loop the first thing python does
is to get an iterator for the object
that you're iterating over then morally
it's just a while true and every
iteration of the loop we get the next
item out of the iterator and then run
the body of the loop which in this case
is print but there's the obvious error
with this approach which is this is just
a while true it's an infinite loop how
is it supposed to end the design
decision that python chose is to have an
iterator's next call raise an exception
in order to specify that the iterator is
done
running the code as is specifically we
see that it raises a stop iteration
exception
if this feels weird to you don't worry
you're in good company this is pretty
weird by their nature exceptions are
kind of supposed to be exceptional
but in python you get an exception with
every single for loop and that's just
the way it is that's the normal way to
end a for loop is to have this next call
raise a stop iteration for our next
iteration pun intended of course we'll
just try to catch that stop iteration
and then break out of the while loop
once we receive it
this version actually works we get one
two three and then the process ends
normally with no errors
but there's still a small bug with this
implementation comment down below if you
can see what it is i'll give you a few
seconds
[Applause]
[Music]
okay if you're ready here's what i mean
what happens if something besides the
iterator something in the body of the
for loop raises that same stop iteration
python doesn't consider that a normal
way to terminate the for loop and we see
the exception bubble up
but in our implementation if we raise a
stop iteration here
then we see nothing because we're
specifically catching stop iterations
inside of our tri-accept
so the issue here is that our tri-accept
should only be around this next call not
around the entire body of the loop
the proper way to do this is with a try
except
else this runs the code in the try block
if a stop iteration was raised in the
try part of the try block then it gets
caught here
any other exception bubbles up and if no
exception is raised then the else block
runs
you can kind of read this in your head
as like if exception else do stuff now a
stop iteration from the body of the loop
will bubble up
we can of course check this by running
it
and in the normal case where we're just
printing we see our expected one two
three
take a moment and just pause to let this
kind of sink in every single time that
you use a for loop all of this stuff is
happening and that's the reason that we
have a for loop in the first place
although it's technically possible to
replace any for loop with its equivalent
while loop that would be a huge hassle
and it's very error prone so it's just
better to have a keyword that expresses
that intent more succinctly the only
other thing i wanted to point out about
this for loop structure is that in this
code you can see we have this variable
it which is the iterator
even when you're using the built-in for
this iterator is there somewhere in our
translation using the while loop we
could theoretically access the iterator
inside the body of the loop
but that would not be possible using a
normal for loop
however if you wanted to make the
iterator accessible in the body of the
for loop you could still do that like
this
just manually grab the iterator and pass
it to the for loop this works because
iterators are themselves iterable which
is something i'll talk about in one of
my future videos that's all thanks for
watching thank you to my patrons and
donors for supporting me and don't
forget to slap that like button an odd
number of times see you next time